5 4 3 2
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
mais le pire le pire c'est pas bien tu
penses que c'est cyril finalement d'être
car ça je ne me rappelais yeux alors je
viens je suis un quart d'heure bordeaux
[Musique]
un gala de noël
la saga mara a game manager brian may
m
j'aime bien le toit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime bien les au lycée de drap gris
télé et qui parle qui me laisse croire
sa part à une phrase
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'était autre chose dans laquelle moscou
keibler 4 way le shaq est mais pas en
qualité de vie
mais chaque et bp non mais qu'est ce que
tu fais quand même mais il a aussi tiré
parti de même pas parlé avec toute façon
je me regarde toi à l'antenne et la tête
ou bossus que tu parles charles
notre dame la table sur mon berceau
[Rires]
non c'est pour bétonner